[Music]
apex legends year two was a
transformative period for the battle
royale game
let's look back at just how much the
game has evolved in the past year
if you enjoyed this recap we'd
appreciate it if you liked the video and
subscribe to the channel for more apex
without further ado let's talk about the
year that was for apex legends
apex legends year 2 started in february
2020 with season 4
assimilation the season added revenant
as a playable character
and the sentinel sniper rifle as a new
weapon the sentinel is the first of its
kind for apex legends as it can be
charged to fire more powerful shots
to lessen the impact of the sentinel and
sniper rifles in general
sniper rifles were given their own ammo
pool limiting your inventory space
one of the most open-ended areas of
world's edge fuel depot
and the field around it also became the
landing ground for a massive harvester
removing a major sniper sight line and
splitting the map down the middle
respawn also used the new year to take a
good look at weapon balancing in regards
to energy weapons
the devotion was moved into care
packages and the l-star became a general
loot weapon
the turbocharger was also removed
nerfing the havoc
though several characters had undergone
buffs nerfs and other balancing changes
throughout year 1
year 2 saw more drastic updates to
characters in order to change
how you played as them season 4 kicked
that off with a major adjustment to
bloodhound buffing their ability to
track down enemy squads
in march system override added evo
shields the shields were a game changer
they started as the weakest body armor
in the game but grew more powerful as
you damaged enemies eventually
surpassing purple
and gold armor in terms of protection in
this way they encouraged players to move
away from staying put and bunkering down
a strategy that had become all too
common since the introduction of watson
in season 2. players were receptive to
evo shields
and following the event respawn
permanently added them to apex legends
up next the old ways event permanently
brought back duo's mode and king's
canyon with a new map rotation feature
the event also added bloodhound's trials
to world's edge blue loot bins with
secret compartments that only lifeline
can open
and a huge buff to revenant in may
season 5 fortune's favor added loba to
apex legends
following pathfinder's transformation
into a recon character lobo became apex
legend's second support legend alongside
lifeline
loba's ability to supply teammates with
any item made her the more useful of the
two though sparking conversations that
lifeline was due for a buff
also in season 5 respawn pulled the now
way too dominant peacekeeper shotgun
from the general loot pool
it went into care packages switching
places with the mastiff shotgun
to account for all of apex legend's
evolving narrative threads
a new story-driven pve mode quest was
added
quest encouraged players to tune in
every week for new lore and revelations
like a serial tv show conditional legend
chatter was also added to reflect the
now changing relationships between the
playable characters
it was a cool way to address the problem
that other hero shooters usually ignore
that's strange matchups where enemies
are suddenly just
working together in a first for apex
legends one of its original characters
got a significant rework in season 5
with all three of mirage's abilities
changing in order to make him a more
successful trickster
other characters would get updated
abilities later in season 5 during its
lost treasures event
lifeline's combat medic passive was
replaced with combat revive
making her the only legend who can
revive a squad mate and fight
simultaneously
octane's jump pad was changed to allow
players to double jump off it making it
easier to aggressively push on fights
watson's intercept pylon no longer
remained indefinitely to reinforce her
role as a strategic defender
that focused on careful placement and
wraith's phase walk was altered so that
it was slower to activate but she can
now
see enemies while using it making its
use less for escape and more so for
repositioning while attacking
loba's introduction also marked the
destruction of skulltown the most
popular drop spot in the entire game
reinforcing the notion that respawn
wasn't above taking away what players
loved in order to shake up apex legends
meta
and craft new experiences however it
became increasingly obvious as time went
on that skull town's destruction had
seriously messed with the overall
balance of king's canyon
the loss of the landmark had made apex
legends smallest map feel even smaller
the addition of krypto's map room during
lost treasures did not help lost
treasures also saw the introduction of
mobile respawn beacons providing a way
for players to bring back teammates from
anywhere
in august season 6 boosted introduced
rampart as a playable character
a weapon modder who excels with light
machine guns interestingly rampart
is the sixth apex legends character to
use the titanfall 2 pilot ability
as the basis for her tactical as her
amped wall is a variation on titanfall
2's a wall
this just leaves cloak as the only
remaining titanfall 2 pilot ability to
not have provided inspiration for a new
apex legends character
and speaking of titanfall 2 season 6 saw
the introduction of the volt
a fan favorite submachine gun from
respawn sophomore effort
season 6 saw world's edge get another
makeover
the devotion also returned to the
general loop pool as did the
turbocharger hop up
meanwhile the r99 was rotated into care
packages
quest was also changed instead of pve
missions the mode now offers a new issue
of the apex legends comic every season
with new pages for each issue unlocked
on a weekly basis
this is a better way to relay apex
legend story it was too difficult to
read text conversations while fighting
off enemies in pve missions
in season 6 the entire recon class was
changed that they all gained
pathfinder's ability to hack into survey
beacons and reveal the position of the
next ring for their squad
krypto was also buffed beyond the new
passive ability finally giving the
legend with one of the lowest pick rates
some much needed utility with the
exception of gold body armor all body
armor became evo shields in season 6 and
all players now drop with evo shields
already equipped
albeit at level 0. it wasn't perfect at
first far from it actually
evo shields were initially way too weak
to compensate for apex legend's
aggressive meta but respawn would
continue to tweak and rebalance evo
shields in the first few weeks of the
season and they're now at a really good
place
season 6 also added crafting through the
collection of materials during a match
players could go to replicators and
craft ammo weapon hop-ups and
attachments evil shielded improvements
and
more like mobile respawn beacons
replicators allowed squads to exist and
fight for a little longer
even after suffering setbacks and the
hunt for more materials encouraged
squads to remain mobile
in october the aftermarket event
introduced cross-play support
a less popular change aftermarket also
adjusted wraith's running animation
forcing the character into a more
upright run in order to make her
incredibly tiny hitbox much easier to
hit
fans were and honestly still are a bit
miffed about the change but it's
admittedly a good one considering that
wraith continues to dominate in all
aspects of play
making her easier to shoot is a far more
agreeable adjustment to just nerfing her
abilities again
it's new shadow royale mode is the first
time that titanfall 2's wall running was
implemented into apex legends
if only for a limited time horizon a
gravitational manipulator who can change
the layout of a battlefield when
attacking was added to apex legends in
season 7 ascension
which started in november horizon
dropped into the game already plenty
powerful her ability to quickly ascend
to multiple stories
or drag enemies out of cover makes her
terrifyingly adaptable
the r99 rejoined the general loot pool
while the prowler submachine gun became
a care package weapon
the select fire hop-up was removed
replaced by quickdraw holster
apex legends was also released for steam
and to ensure that players across all
platforms could more easily find others
to squad up with
in-game clubs were implemented the
season added a brand new map to apex
legends
olympus where players could drive the
game's first vehicles tridents
as the game's third map olympus feels
like respawn's best effort yet
the lack of too many open deserts or
fields prevents snipers from being
overpowered
olympus is a packed map only more so
after january's fight night event which
added the fight night ring
tridents have been an intriguing albeit
disappointing experiment
they are strictly a means of getting
around and present no offensive or
defensive threat
in fact your squad is at a disadvantage
by riding in one as you all take damage
from enemy attacks if the trident is hit
they're also incredibly noisy very few
people ride in tridents now which makes
the vehicles feel
essentially moot at the start of season
7 respawn also completely reworked the
point system and structure for
challenges and battle fast levels
the new system rewarded long-term
investment so instead of progressing
through the battle pass at a fairly
consistent rate
the new system rewarded very little up
front only unlocking a flurry of battle
past levels after investing many many
hours of play
additionally challenges were much more
specific requiring players to complete
some of them with a certain legend as
opposed to having the option of three or
four different characters
this made it unfair for anyone who
hadn't bought all of apex legend's nine
extra characters which now vastly
outnumbered the six
free characters fans were very vocal
about their displeasure with these
changes
but to response credit the developer
quickly implemented hotfixes that
ultimately changed season 7's battle
pass and challenges
so that progression matched that scene
in season 6.
and with that you're all caught up on
the biggest changes that happened apex
legends in year two
how do you feel about the year and what
was your favorite change that respawn
made
sound off in the comments below if you
want to go back and look at our year 1
retrospective
hit the link and consider subscribing
for more apex legends
[Music]
[Music]
you